I've
said a lot of times, I don't remember the
number that we just can't afford to wait until
the week before a major election to call out
voter suppression and voter purges.
And I'm trying to make good on that.
And today we're 10 and a half, 11 months out
from the election, and we have news once again
that Georgia Republicans are purging hundreds
of thousands of voters from the voter rolls.
They did this in the lead up to the 2018 election
in Georgia.
You might remember this at least played a
role.
I won't say it was the factor that denied
democratic gubernatorial candidate Stacey
Abrams the win, but it played a role in her
not winning that election.
And once again, we have the Georgia, a Republican
secretary of state, Brad Reffind, [inaudible]
purging voters by the hundreds of thousands
and a federal judge has decided this week
that they can go ahead and remove 300,000
voters that they say are inactive.
Now, of course you might say, well, you know,
inactive sounds like dead people.
People who move to other States and are voting
elsewhere, they should be removed from voter
rolls, right?
Very, very wrong.
More than 120,000 of those 300,000 people
who are being removed are being removed merely
because they've not voted for a while.
This is not a good reason to remove them,
and this will lead to people who do want to
vote in November who are notified about their
removal at an old address and they might want
to vote to remove the remove Donald Trump
in November and they will show up and be told,
sorry, you're not registered in Georgia.
You are allowed to register to vote only until
the fifth Monday before election day.
That means if you don't realize you've been
purged until election day, you're out of luck
and you're not going to be able to vote.
Now let's look at the numbers.
A little bit.
300,000 voters, that's 4% of the Georgia electorate.
In 2016 Donald Trump won in Georgia 50 to
45 that's five points.
If it's closer to this time around, it might
only be a two or three point margin in Georgia,
and we are talking about removing 4% of the
electorate by purging them due to inactivity.
A bad faith actor could strategically purge
only so-called inactive voters that they determine
based on geography or for other reasons, are
more likely to be democratic voters rather
than Republican voters and could at least
hypothetically swing an election with these
voter purges.
Meanwhile, it's not just Georgia.
I know this is happening in a lot of States
today.
All high.
I've highlighted Georgia already.
Something similar is happening in Wisconsin.
Wisconsin, you might remember was a key state
in 2016 uh, Wisconsin was one of the States
that pushed Trump to an electoral college
victory with a combined 75,000 votes across
only three States.
Wisconsin is purging 234,000 voters.
This is 7% of the electorate there.
Remember that in Wisconsin, Trump won not
by five, but by 0.77% it was just 22,000 votes.
They are purging more than 10 times the margin
of victory in 2016 234,000 voters.
So what the hell do we do?
There's the individual level and then there's
the systemic level at the individual level.
Number one, check your status and check it.
Often we have a link in the description for
the YouTube clip for this story, but you can
also find it by Googling usa.gov confirm you're
registered to vote.
They have a page called confirm that you're
registered to vote@usa.gov which we'll show
you how to do it.
Keep checking it you if you, is it usa.gov.com
now I'm forgetting.
I'm sure you can find the page.
If you notice that you're not registered,
get registered.
Big picture.
We've got to end this concept of voter registration.
The concept at its core should be eliminated.
Number one, we should be automatically registering
everybody when they get a driver's license
or take other actions, but that's not even
really the solution.
The big picture is if you're 18 years old,
you should just be registered automatically.
The concept of registration is what needs
to be done away with in many countries, this
is the way it works.
You're a citizen.
Oh, you just show up and vote.
You don't have to have registered.
You don't have to have filled out a form.
You don't have to have told someone, I am
signaling my intent to vote at some point
in the future.
If you are a citizen, you can vote.
Trump says Democrats can't win without impeachment.
They can't win without dirty dossiers or other
techniques that are untoward subterfuge of
different kinds.
It really seems like it's Republicans who
know they can't win without voter suppression,
who know they can't win if they don't work
to reduce the number of people that ultimately
will vote and it is well underway.
So I, it's we're 10 and a half months away.
We know that the number of stories about voter
suppression will ramp up close to the election.
The Georgia voter suppression story in 2018
only got significant coverage in like the
six weeks before and it was too late and it
was a big part of why Stacey Abrams lost that
gubernatorial election.
Let's start now.
We should all be checking our registration
status.
We should all be activists.
You know, I talked earlier in the show.
It's actually kind of a good segue into it.
About the 600 plus rallies that took place
yesterday, uh, in favor of Donald Trump's
impeachment.
It's great.
I love seeing a national, um, uh, national
turnout in this way, uh, on a relatively short
notice to activate for or against different
things.
And in this case, for the impeachment, Donald
Trump, uh, I've said before, we really need
mass rallies in this country.
We need mass rallies and urban centers.
We need to consider other activism techniques
that are go, that are beyond faxing.
You're a member of Congress or signing an
online petition.
When it comes to voter suppression.
This is one of the foremost issues of our
time when we talk about the climate.
When we talk about inequality, when we talk
about voter suppression, voter suppression,
and our ability to even decide who it is that
will represent us on all of those other issues,
it is one of the most important things that
we can do.
And we need activism around it.
And I hope that we
will
see
it big, strong, powerful.